I'm all warmed up
just as I got my tango shoes on.
We are here to set a tangle record.
Where is Willmar?
Willmar.
[inaudible]
can I had a dream about this once.
Okay.
So do you think you can
dance? Um, I hope so.
They do.
They help you set a new Guinness Book of
World Records for the most tango spins
in one minute. So please welcome
Ferris and Elise, the among
de [inaudible]
Seattle. Okay, let me ask you a question
now. All right. Where are your sleeves?
Seriously, you're such a good tango
dancer. Where's your sleeves? Nervously?
I left him in the back room. I
forgot them. How you get into tango?
Well,
I was a complete workaholic 1994 and uh,
I just left the country with a backpack
and a one way trip to Europe for four
weeks of supposed to recharge.
My batteries just gone for 15 months.
I'm in Argentina where I took a
class just for no real good reason.
And there were 10 women in the class
and two guys. And you like those odds?
I like the odds. I like the
ratio signed up and here we are.
It's incredible. And did you
meet there? Is that how you
yeah, she was actually
one of my teachers and uh,
I became a complete fanatic about tango
and started doing it for eight hours a
day and uh,
we decided to compete and
the rest is history.
Okay,
well you are going to teach us how to do
a proper tango spin. So can you show us?
So tango with the fines
and tango is the embrace.
So you were talking about sexy spins. Yes.
Start right here. It's chest, the chest,
chest to chest.
I'll put what would should be my choice.
Okay.
[inaudible]
first thing the woman is going to do is
she's going to pivot back and backstep
with,
in this case her left foot,
left foot and the man is going to
follow with his foot extended here.
He's basically tracing her rear
foot and then come to round.
You backstep Kelly, you're
gonna take a sidestep.
Okay.
It's like this. So all
told, hey we show, okay.
Is
it a woman's part? Looks
like this. So Mack Mack
side, back side of the rights. No,
back to the left.
Take a side step with the right.
I know you're going to step forward
with the left foot around him. Forward.
Right Oyster on standing up.
You're going to pivot on your left foot.
Okay. So that you're facing him again.
Wilbur. This apart with,
with, with Wilmer's.
Exactly what it is,
what it looks like.
Like that. So that's what the spin
looks like. And then I turned,
wow.
That's exactly what we're going to do.
You get to the point here, which is
you to setting a new world records now
[inaudible]
and the time to beat is a 27
spins in 60 seconds. Okay. Stuart,
when you're ready,
you give them the go ahead.
Okay, Tim, let's say you're ready.
Ready? Okay. Three, two, one. Go.
[inaudible] [inaudible] it'd be terrible.
Stuart, what's the word? Do we
have a new record? Uh, we, uh,
we certainly do that Guinness Record Role
[inaudible] was 27 is now thoughts he
sat on couldn't got to license.
Well done.
[inaudible].